welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity Trump versus the swamp the
president's battle against the
intolerant left is symptomatic of a
broader disconnect in our culture
Beltway elitists who haven't discussed
for America's heartland beloved actor
Chris Pratt well known for honoring the
troops in making surprise visits to sick
children is under attack he famously
gave a nine rules speech to young people
at the MTV Movie and TV Awards in June
telling them quote God is real God loves
you God wants the best for you believe
that I do and learn to pray it's easy
and it's so good for your soul unquote
it looks like the Hollywood star has
angered the left even further a TV Guide
editor lambasted him as problematic for
being a lover of hunting and raising
lambs the guide ran an article titled
how to love Chris Pratt without hating
yourself
it takes issue with Pratt's
farm-to-table lifestyle and hunting deer
he even eats meat oh my goodness here to
discuss the Liberals disconnect with the
mainstream media with the mainstream
America I should say his turning point
u.s. a founder charlie kirk kirk and
trump advisory board member and attorney
madison jesse otto i got to tell you
charlie the disconnect here could not be
further I mean Chris Pratt is saying I
like hunting I like God and I like
praying
why is he constantly under attack when
this is so important Jason because now
we have seen that it's no longer a
political divide in our country it's now
becoming a cultural divide these used to
be things that the Democrat Party used
to embrace I mean the Democrat Party the
67 these and 80s they used to be a party
of fear and reverence of God that
understood the lifestyle of mainstream
America and the Heartland which is
hunting and fishing and and family no
longer it is now a party which as Andrew
Breitbart told us politics goes
downstream from culture that has now
gone towards this kind of cultural
relativism which is rooted in there is
no God that hunting is wrong that meat
is evil and I know it sounds so absurd
to people to hear this but the
is really a lifestyle that you'll find
in Manhattan and Malibu but there's a
middle part of the country that is
rejecting this wholeheartedly and you
see and you see this with Chris Pratt my
heart goes out to him because he's just
a good red-blooded American who now
still believes in God and country and
he's getting absolutely targeted
attacked by these Hollywood and
Manhattan elites and there's very very
hard to speak out in Hollywood because
of that now Madison look Chris Pratt is
a very entertaining entertainer I mean
these his movies he puts a smile on your
face but he now has a target on his back
right because he likes to hunt he raises
lamb that he ends up eating I mean he's
living the way the overwhelming majority
of Americans live but he does now have a
target on his back doesn't he you know
Jay said I can't help but think that
people have bigger things to worry about
than what Chris Pratt's eating or where
his food is coming from and I can assure
those people that most people in this
country get food that comes from much
worse places than where Chris's foods
coming from chris is a great guy and the
problem here is not that chris is a
hunter the problem here that chris is
that chris is a Christian that Chris is
not liberal
so he doesn't fit in with the media he
doesn't fit in with the Hollywood elites
and they can't handle that he's amazing
on screen he's done incredible things
off screen he's worked with Special
Olympics he's raised money for families
of children with cancer
he's just overall a great guy he's a
classy guy he's a believer of God and
he's someone that so many young people
across this country could look up to and
he's someone who just takes time out of
his day to do nice things for others you
know he even said he took the time to
send me a message when I passed the bar
exam congratulating me I've been
impressed with him his entire career and
I wish the Liberals would stop showing
their bias because guess what he's
someone that we should look to not not
something that we should be attacking so
Charlie the the Liberals they take this
approach and they want to go after
people that that hunt they pray and they
believe in God how in the world are they
gonna grow their party if they think
that that's what's representative of
America well part of their political
strategy is to try to allow 10 to 15
million illegal immigrants into the
country hopefully naturalize them get
the right to vote and therefore they
don't have to win back middle America I
know that sounds cynical and sinister
but the Democrats I mean are well on
their way to do that but I'll say this
Jason it's so it's so important that
people have to realize that we are now
in the midst of a culture war in our
country which is are we still a country
that believes in the idea of a pluribus
unum or In God We Trust and liberty
these are the foundational
judeo-christian values of our country
that made America the greatest country
and greatest culture ever to exist and
and look it's it's we have gone so far
outside of the rails of reality when
some like Chris Pratt is a talk attacked
by this and by the way why should have
chatter like this that he does I got
it's gotta cut you off there I have a
heart out I got a meet in Madison Sean
Hannity owes you more time on Hannity so
somehow I'll work that out with him but
we really appreciate you both joining us
here today